das war eine geplante andere von
jugendrecht ich wollte mir irgendwie das
an die substanz unterjubeln weil ich
letztes mal bestimmt irgendwas von denen
nicht gut bewertet habe oder so und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ja weil ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
mir auch danke ich will es kurz machen
abonnierte in den kanal bitte kurz das
sage ich jedes mal aber ich glaub ich
das ist jetzt fast so lange bis für die
eine million dollar ist nicht mehr so
viele deswegen okay gut kommen wir zum
thema und zwar habe ich noch ein video
geplant das ist schon ein bisschen
länger geplant die sachen ding ja schon
ein bisschen länger um ihr wisst es ja
hallo ich schon drauf gefilmt naja ihr
habt ja schon am titel gelesen ich habe
schon sehr auf 10 kostenlose gadgets von
milch getestet auch zweimal schon von
human und heute haben ihn auf den
dritten plätzen part und reich zu
erstmal damit ich weiß aber die sachen
lagen hier noch und deswegen es sind
auch coole sachen dabei muss ich sagen
ich würde sagen wir setzen sehr kurz hin
und schaut mal hier jedoch aus oder wie
auf dem bild wie im film fernsehen ja
123456 sache da eigentlich sind überall
zwei photonen gewähren sogar 12 12 sagt
unglaublich heute und ich würde sagen
doch nach oben
wir fangen an und ich sage ja auch jedes
mal die können wir sehr gerne weitere
produkte stecken wenn ihr irgendwas
findet auf irgendeiner seite was ich
machen soll
tipps weiter auf install am boden da hat
sich alex pietsch 12
dann wollen wir doch mal reinschauen das
ist irgendwie ein licht für ein auto
also so ein indoor nicht wie man hier
sehen kann zu magna
[Musik]
zwei stück sogar insgesamt dann steht da
nicht drauf wie es gemacht wird
ich will gar nix drauf aber jetzt habe
ich es cool man muss die knopf batterie
hier zwischen stecken dann kann man das
hier das ganz schön hält dann kann man
es wieder rein ballern und jetzt zu
drehen dann kannst du das hier hinten
war dass das licht ist geil was ist das
über das ist irgendwie fürs auto oder
generell worauf auch immer bock hast
jetzt kann man das zum beispiel sage ich
mal macht noch einen kühlschrank sowie
dem bombenanschlag auf das bringt der ex
ungefähr nach das ist diese dumme kraft
batterie leer wie der schmetterling
wieder schmetterlinge im café
ich weiß nicht ich habe mir das
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich war das
produktbild wieder so dass man sich
gedacht hat das cover darstellen
und jetzt kommt ihr sowas einen wollen
wir es nicht mal aus dem schalter dran
mit dem man es an und ausmachen können
das heißt wenn du jetzt wieder aus
machen willst musst du die knopf
batterie wieder rausnehmen
was ist das geschichten aus shenzen nein
machen wir mal direkt weiter all das
macht muster das blieb den
unterschiedlichen sachen weißt du was
das ist lichtschwert nein das ist fürs
fahrrad a scheiße aber das ist keine
batterie bei was ist hier drin ist ein
reflektor meister
das heißt wenn es angestrahlt wird wenn
er zum beispiel nachts durch die gegend
fährt mit seinem fahrrad und dann ist
das praktisch immer
es ist wie so ein ventil also hier
kannst du deinen rat zu schrauben wir
haben jetzt hier zum beispiel sonst
ersatz ventil das ding kommt ein aufgeld
ventil drauf und ist dann praktisch wie
so leicht schwert und an einem
fahrradreifen dran und dann es also
eigentlich schon ein bisschen
unnatürlich man kann auch einmal so ein
katzenauge nehmen das ist ganz wichtig
vorschrift wenn ihr das nicht drin hast
bei der fahrradprüfung auf jedem klasse
dann kannst du dir was anderen von der
polizei
wenn die katzenaugen nicht drin sind
woher ich muss sagen das war eine sache
noch nicht so naja machen wir mal weiter
[Applaus]
das habe ich natürlich scheiße bestellen
das hat mir irgendwie gerade auch ein
bisschen wacklig das gummi insekten
bestellt
guck mal das ist so ein linken masse
unter wasser ist hier ist eine palme
die jetzt von kaputt ist was findet
palme hier ist eine trug die habe ich
jetzt gerade aus versehen
auseinandergerissen
das ist der strenge von der palme und
das sind oben gibt ja warum warum warum
warum warum das war man sich dann auch
im endeffekt immer warum nicht mal so
dinge die du gegen die wand klatschen
kannst du haben die kleben da nicht
kennst du musst also wann egal wir
kommen noch zu höhepunkt also die besten
foto gekommen sagt unterschätzt das
produkt nicht weißt was das ist eine
balance zu liga diese verpackung führt
das produkt ich würde mir auch jetzt
raten wir sind vielleicht also muss ich
sagen
normalerweise ist das nicht so also ich
verstehe ist wenn jetzt wollen sagen
alex schrittes like the product ausbeute
heute ich bin ja sowieso hier immer die
produkte ein
aber guck mal deswegen habe ich zum
beispiel dieses laserschwert bestellt
wegen diesem foto
ja meinte dass die entsteht dann so nur
weil es gar nicht leuchtet das wär
verarschen ich warte jetzt war ich habe
ich habe ihr aber keine brillen ich habe
kein break oder so bestellt also und
jetzt habe ich nicht bestellen was soll
als wenn nicht sowas bestehen würde
es ist hier nicht weil er den produkten
ich weiß nicht woher es kommt aber das
hat man manchmal irgendwie wenn man da
so viel bestellt das dann aber manchmal
irgendwas ankommt wir hatten es auch
schon im ersten part
da habe ich ja ganz viele luftballons
passt auch das ist ein geiles kälte und
zwar ein verdoppelter aux-anschluss aber
nicht nur das den kann man sich an
schlüsselbund an machen dann hat man
immer dabei
weißt du wer kennt die situation scheint
jetzt für die wieder der aus anschluss
und auch noch ein doppelter werden
jedoch gut und dann sag ich leute kein
problem wollen raus und zieht es raus
und jeder alle gucken dummen genau
deswegen habe ich es bestellt also wer
sowas braucht das gibt es müssen wir wir
haben auf jeden fall noch bessere sachen
warte machen leute wirklich schaltet
noch nicht ab es kommt noch was momentan
tut mir gut
wein ist das eine sportuhr die habe ich
gehört gesehen ich bin es natürlich eine
silikon band digitale led sport armband
edle armbanduhr heißt das produkt und
eigentlich kann das auch die uhrzeit
anzeigen wahrscheinlich ist nur die
batterie leer an jetzt hier kann zogen
nicht anschalten ich habe sogar schon
versucht die batterie slam also
eigentlich ist das halt nur aber das war
noch längst nicht das coole denn die
coolen sachen die kommen erst jetzt muss
nicht sein
doch das ist guck mal das ist eine
eigene schweiß muschel
nehmen wir nur wenn man schnell
korrigieren das ist ein original im jahr
kommender zahn vom weißen hai megalodon
dem urteil ganz selten habe ich damals
gemacht bei ihm und er führt auch hier
ist wie stark das ist ja das ist
lediglich ein zahn also was man damit
wohl schon dinosaurier getötet damals
man sich muss dass man kurs überprüfe
das waren von mega dollar ich habe also
ohne scheiß jetzt ich habe das nicht
bestellt ohne scheint ich hab's nicht
bestellt du kannst dir durchgucken meine
ganzen sachen es ist es ist nicht dabei
und es war ja in der jungen verpackung
langsam bin ich mich vor beschwerden von
die weitere einführung unter helfen
ich weiß nicht auf marbachweg bitte
nicht mal deine freunde damit jetzt wird
türkisch der habe ich war stiegen die
krise das liest du das war grausam
das war nicht gut dass das war ein
geplanter angriff von jugend auf mich
ich wollte mir irgendwie das andere
substanz unter jubel weil ich letztes
mal bestimmt irgendwas von denen nicht
gut bewertet haben oder so vielleicht
denkt jetzt ich meine das ironisch aber
ich habe diese muschel nicht bestellt
ich habe es wirklich nicht bestellt als
wenn ich eine bushaltestelle auch immer
muskel die kaufen jetzt damit gehe ich
den stones haus also wenn das richtig
cool ist nicht das ist was genial ist
natürlich jetzt noch drin haben weisst
du wirst überrascht sein aber das habe
ich schon mal liebe stellt immer so so
was ist das alter das ist schon geil
qualität auch die qualität ist naiv
das hält auch richtig gut hier und da
und dann gehst du damit hier einfach so
kannst du das ist halt für einen abend
gedacht nee ist anscheinend nicht mehr
das ist das trainierte meinung dass
sowas überhaupt verkauft werden leute
ich schwöre euch jetzt habe ich alles in
voller fehlen ich werde nie wieder bei
ihm bestellen ehrlich da kommt ja so ne
also zumindest nicht diese kostenlose
karte was ist denn das wer bestellt denn
sowas her das rad also dann kannst du
auch gleich gar nichts herstellen ist ja
besser verteilten aufkleber von ort a ha
ich würde erstmal toiletten aufkleber
stimmt einfach nicht lustig weil wir
haben doch schon einige unserer toilette
den können wir noch dazu kämen aber
heute mal so kann man das werk
einstecken
das mache ich wenn ich in irgendeiner
barmen dann nehme ich das mit und
erklärt dass der 1
das ist was genial es hier so
und da ist mir dann so schwer
investitionen aus und dann kann man sein
handy halt so hinstellen oder auch am
besten wahrscheinlich
das ist eigentlich ein gutes ding weil
bei den popstars zb wenn dein handy so
groß ist wie mainz das hält manchmal
nicht traue mich schon gar nicht mehr
euch das zu zeigen
also ich muss weg es tut mir wirklich
ein bisschen live wollte ich verspreche
euch ich mag solche videos nehmen wir
das ist kompletter quatsch ich bin
ehrlich zu euch wirklich bei den ersten
dreier spaß hatten wir keine kohle
wirklich coole produkte dabei da
zumindest richtig spaß gemacht aber hier
ist wirklich nur müll angekommen die
hälfte habe ich darf man nicht mehr
bestellt wenn ich an diese muschel denke
also ich würde am liebsten selber im
video und das land gebe mache ich auch
mit meinem eigenen kanal sonne scheiße
hier
na ja trotzdem ansehen wir uns morgen um
19 uhr gibt es ein neues video und
hinten
das klingt für mich nicht mehr leute das
war's ich hab einfach unglaublich achso
bewegungsmelder überall rein